how tough is that turnaround on the body
honestly is it really tough like Sunday
to Sunday yeah on that Sunday to Sunday
oh it's I like I don't get that it's
hard to understand yeah no it's
literally I'm in a car accident every
Sunday multiple car accidents every
Sunday like oh damn multiple every
Sunday and like like I said earlier like
there's a part of luck to it like like
there's a game like I've had games where
like I hyper extend my knee and like
that's gonna that's gonna affect your
season like that's gonna be there or you
burst a bursa sack in your knee that's
going to be there for several weeks and
if you get lucky you don't have to deal
with that stuff it's a little bit better
but like you're still getting these car
accidents and like Monday you actually
like Monday I have to do like a big
lower body lift I have to move otherwise
you get really stiff and like you get
more sore so you do a big lift try to
say a little bit mobile but Mondays I
usually feel okay Tuesdays are really
really hard days like it's like the
second day afterwards you kind of feel
everything Whiplash kind of yeah it's
literally what it is and like there and
there's some Tuesdays are better than
others like some like and especially
like if we play on the East Coast like a
five hour flight back I get home at four
a.m those are tough but um like you get
in these car accidents and like it takes
like Thursday to Fridays when I start to
feel like myself again
and it's and then like the longer end of
this the more into the season you get
the more like your body it's wear and
tear wear and tear wear and tears are
like really not like how I see it is as
if if I'm not doing football I'm doing
recovery whether it's tubs whether it's
bfr workouts whether it's just movement
yoga
um red light therapy saunas like
whatever it is that can make my body
hyperbaric chambers are big now
um whatever is like available I that's
all I do like I get home from practice I
get home at like let's just say on a
Wednesday I'll be home at like 6 6 30.
I'm instantly my next two and a half
hours are rehab and I can afford to have
a lot of that stuff in my house now so
that I get home fast I can hang with my
wife for longer because like my first
two years and my first three years in
the league I was at the facility for
Mike
are they our meeting started let's say
for me to start at eight I'm there from
6 15 until like 7 30 8 o'clock at night
for like yeah it's just it's a long day
especially and then like I want to be
home I want to be with my wife
um and so it's just like I've purchased
those things I have in my house and so I
just I have a couple extra hours but
like Larry that's all you do now is
rehabbing Rehabilitation and there are
guys that don't do that I don't know how
they survive I don't understand it yeah
it's it's actually crazy like some guys
like they don't have to do all that
stuff but that's something I'd like I've
dedicated my well I mean like the
football window is like I said the
average lifespan's three years so I mean
like the window in the grand scheme of
my life uh my college my rookie sorry my
freshman year at a coach uh David Wright
told me this he was like I drew on a
board is like if you line here and lie
here let's just say it's 100 years right
that's your life I'll do it so you can
see it 100 years this is zero
and like so here you are you're 18 years
old you're right here
this four-year window of college is this
big
and then you have the rest of your life
why not take advantage of that small ass
window right do everything you can to be
the best you can do this four years so
now after college now you get a chance
in the NFL and now you're getting to
think now it's this big it's a bigger
window but it's still like a sliver it's
like 12 to 12 years of your life yeah
one tenth of your life and so like why
not put all your effort into being
available and being the best player you
can possibly be
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one